so tired I want to just put my feet up
wow she just like I am yeah right there
oh my God an American flag you like a
North Korean one no have a North Korean
one than American flag me too American
flag is a red flag American flag is a
red flag she looks pretty American cuz
she's fat something that really bothers
me and like honestly has given me a
sense of a little bit of an insecurity
is the fact that yeah like there are all
these women like throwing them M
themselves but me like the past 10 years
like I don't have any of that like I
have zero this sounds weird but like
male attention for for who you're Mar
like why do these women it's they're
they're wives and mothers asking for
male attention guys at some point it's
going to go all right it's not going to
last forever you will be a grandmother
yes nobody's checking for Grandma I'm
sorry not even
Madonna what up guys welcome to the
chest curly than YouTube channel and
welcome to my reaction series before I
start make sure you like the video on
your way in as that is the most
important metric that YouTube uses to
push out these streams also guys get
yourself a women shouldn't vote t-shirt
today if you want to be the ultimate
alpha male that women come up to left
and right and just say you are so
amazing and awesome get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt so today I am
going to be reacting to women hitting
the wall so for those of you that don't
know the wall is is highly disputed on
the eight some people say women hit the
wall at 25 other people say women hit
the wall at 35 but let's just for
argument sake say it's somewhere between
the ages of 25 and 35 where a woman
realizes that her sexual agency is not
what it used to be let's say a woman is
used to this much attention now at 18
she got this much attention now at 28
she gets this much attention that is
what we call the wall
yes yes yes um on average I would say
it's 27 28 29 30 is roughly when the
wall happens some women it's a couple
years later because they take care of
themselves some women it's a couple
years earlier because they get fat and
they're big fatty um so today we're
going to be reacting to women hitting
the
wall
29 it's my guess 29 28 your
fought for women to get jobs
why why did we do that okay funny thing
funny thing it's actually funny how
women think that their lives are harder
today than they would have been 150
years ago yes you absolutely were
married and at home with the kids 150
years ago but what do you broads think
we were doing do you think we just sat
there and were just pampered and doed
upon if it was actually quite customary
to serve your husband back then and you
actually probably worked on a farm yeah
do you think Google guys I talk about
the Amish all the time Google a day in
the life of the Amish watch one of those
videos and tell me easier or harder than
your average 9 to5 human resources job
just asking questions so tired I want to
just put my feet up wow she just like do
you know what they call it they call it
like I I don't even like saying this
because it's kind of out there but the a
thousand SK it's like the a thousand
[__] you know stare where it's like it's
almost like there's like a dead in her
eyes like I am yeah right there oh my
God didn't you know this is what
equality feels
[Music]
like the biggest red flag when you go
into a guy's place or a bedroom an
American flag flag you like a North
Korean one no I have a North Korean one
than American flag me too American flag
is a red flag look at American flag is a
red flag she looks pretty American cuz
she's fat that might as well be the new
American flat flag fat people I'm a big
fat slob only American flag is the Nicki
Minaj one it was so sad look at this
chick I'm going to go back she actually
like imagine if she was thin she
actually has a decently pretty face it's
like such a she could be a solid seven
instead she's a two fat slob only
American flag is the Niki like look at
her she's actually pretty then she did
that to her body n one look at these
twoing
pigeons I want a North Korea flag really
[__] go live in North Korea go I'll buy
you
the okay you and your little fat friend
there they say I go over to a guy's
house and he has a big beautiful
American
flag I'm going to let him do some real
nasty things to me as I sare at that
flag you want to know why cuz
freedom on that note I'm going to go
swallow and I grow okay
[Music]
bye something that really bothers me and
like honestly has given me a sense of a
little bit of an insecurity is the fact
that yeah like there are all these women
like throwing themselves but me like the
past 10 years like I don't have any of
that like I have zero this sounds weird
but like male attention cuz I don't want
it right right right but it' be nice to
know that like someone's looking for for
who your mayor like why do these women
it's they're they're wives and mothers
asking for male attention guys at some
point it's going to go all right it's
not going to last forever someday every
if you live long enough you will be a
grandmother yes nobody's checking for
Grandma I'm sorry not even Madonna not
even Madonna nobody is checking for
Grandma this is the sick fact this
shick's got an alpha male that plenty of
women want but she seeks male attention
and has a subconscious or even conscious
desire to have somebody wanting her
besides her husband that's the problem
these days watch out
guys don't not tonight CER i k your ass
I don't know what you want me to do I
don't know what you want me to do I
don't know how I do anything wrong in
the bed I don't get that when all you do
is criticize me oh your head bogus and I
this this this and that like what theu
come on
now wait is that wait wait let me listen
again to what she said hold on wait so
so this driver is talking to her guy I'm
guessing or bitching about him what you
want me to do I don't know how I do
anything wrong in the bed I don't get
that when all you do is criticize me oh
your head bogus and not this this this
and that like what the f come on now
come
on Fellers stop gassing up these butter
faces you drooling mouth Emoji under
repost of some IHOP Flapjacks got these
females thinking they're tens when
they're really negative to scooty
scoot stop sing up guys that should not
work anyways JN be careful there's a
sharp curve coming up hold on to the
waters oh that's
funny
oh oh
[__]
[Applause]
no no oh
god oh she got her purse
back wow at different times of my life
I've chose to intervene in different
situations but it's not always smart
because if that person had a gun you
could lose your life over a stranger so
really think about it I had one guy who
messaged me he's like oh I don't know
what to do I really miss my girl that's
true you're gonna you know what's
interesting you're going to keep seeing
like this lack of shival like you know
quote unquote chivalry and Men helping
women because you know I don't know
we're we're just going to see this
because a lot of times there's
consequences for those guys that do step
I've even heard of guys intervening in
like a situation where a guy's beating
his girlfriend and then he gets beat up
and then the girlfriend still goes home
with the wife beat her so you know like
why'd you split up oh she was talking to
these guys it's like why do you miss her
you know cuz she was my only girl he
wanted her back I said you don't want
her back cuz you know she's a [__]
girlfriend you just don't want to miss
her anymore most these guys are in love
with girls and they don't even want the
girl all they do is argue with the girl
they can't stand her she's a [__]
but they just too much of a [__] to
feel like they miss someone if you're
not afraid of heartbreak and you stick
to your guns you're going to have a
fantastic life with you if you're not
afraid to say sorry not good enough for
me goodbye and stick to it as a [__]
man you're going to do just fine they
say time heals all wounds then tell me
why I still think about the time 3 years
ago when a guy I was dating I asked him
to titty me Titty Bang me and he said um
how would we do that with
you that was information I didn't need I
got to be honest I didn't I didn't
is there any more of that bomb potato
salad yeah where abouts over there
yeah hey yo what the
[__]
nice you what the [__] did you do what
the [__] it's just a it's like a stomach
thing that I get the [__] out of my it's
just like a
stomach [__] so sorry [__]
I don't want to do this if I don't have
you
please please they like revert to
children like I think my siblings had
these temper tantrum okay I had these
temper tantrums when I was sue me Sue me
but I'm just saying like this is like
what a seven-year-old I don't want to do
this if I don't have you
please please me I don't care record me
I don't care cuz I'm
psycho itst I'm not even recording
posted posted I I mean she said he could
technically she's giving consent in this
video I don't care I don't
care
I what [__]
doing is this common you ever seen this
before I've never seen a CH I need you
take me back make sure if this is
happening to you yeah guys this is why
you got to avoid the sleeve tto them you
definitely turn on that phone and record
cuz you never know the story she could
tell if you don't and beware I wouldn't
take him back at this point because it's
a ticking Time Bomb it's a scary
situation and you're the one that's
going to go to jail almost 90% of the
time if you had 24 hours with me and I
couldn't say no what would we do wait
wait I want to answer the question if I
had 20 um I would have her read some
scripts for me yes that is what I would
have her do I would have her I would put
her to work I'd put her in the back and
say here are some scripts that I need
you to read for some essay videos we're
working on chica you know what would you
have her do what work like what what
would we do we need help with she said
if there's 24 hours with her like what
would you do I'm saying like I'd make
her do scripts for like a day or like
reactions I I don't know looks like a
prostitute my my like yeah you have to
give her a job that fits her skill set
what are you saying I'm saying when you
employ people you usually have to give
them jobs that fit their skill sets well
she's a she's talking she's lips sinking
there I'm saying we can never do scripts
oh okay okay well that could work
too it's basically an 8h hour arm
workout and it's made up of 16 mini
workouts every half an hour throughout
the day for 8 hours straight damn not
contradictory it don't matter what the
you think they are do you want a husband
or
not you come in here talking critically
about me do you want one
do you want a
man if you want a man become more
desirable to
men if you don't want a man you don't
got to do nothing to be be more
desirable to men you don't even want a
[__] man but if you do want a man and
you're not willing to adjust yourself to
be more desirable to men you're [__]
delusional you're the
problem if you don't want a man it don't
matter but if you do want a man you
better find out what the [__] they think
and how they
feel or keep doing whatever you've been
doing and keep letting that roll fry
your [__] where you can't even come
with a partner now cuz your [__] [__]
cuz you been you you done electrocuted
your [__] all
right and you and your friends sit
around each other talking about what y'
what y'all think y know about men and
drinking all that wine getting all them
yeast infections and just talking to
each other [__] that y'all know nothing
about frown your [__] up with them
you get a rat and you put it in a cage
and give it two water bottles one is
just water and the other is water Lac
with either heroin or cocaine if you do
that the rat will almost always prefer
the drugged water and almost always kill
itself quite quickly in the 7s Professor
Alexander noticed we're putting the rat
in an empty cage it's got nothing to do
except use these drugs let's try
something a bit different so Professor
Alexander built a cage that he called
rat Park which is basically heaven for
rats they've got loads of cheese they've
got loads of colored balls they've got
loads of tunnels crucially they've got
loads of friends and they've got both
the water bottles the normal water and
the drugged water but here's the
fascinating thing in Rat Park they don't
like the drugged water they almost never
use it none of them ever use it
compulsively none of them ever overdose
you go from Almost 100% overdose when
they're isolated to 0% overdose when
they have happy and connected Liv I know
some of you guys are struggling with
substance abuse out there hang in there
I've I've had that go throughout my
family before but uh you know maybe it's
time to move on change your friends
change your environment make a rat park
for yourself think about it you work
here yeah here you
go for the gender pay Gap sure trying to
level things out got you
[__] don't open your eyes yet but we're
here I can already smell the fish fish
are you joking is it cuz my legs up I
don't shower to save the
environment what what are you what are
you talking about I'm talking about Red
Lobster the date we were supposed to you
know what never a man is going to go
where he feels like a man sometimes if
you don't build up your man and make him
feel like a man even when he's wrong but
you still don't dishonor him he's going
to stay with you but if you beat him up
or if you if you are nasty to him or you
just treat him like trash go somewhere
else get that all right this is one of
those daytime shows like the view or
something they never advocate for men
but uh she's pretty spot on here I can't
believe it there's a coldness too bad
she still got the that you have to
accept when you a man only women
children and
dogs are loved unconditionally a man is
only loved under the condition that he
provides them all right guys you know oh
no no world where they PR promote
nothing but tolerance I think it's
important to remember to never be
ashamed to establish your boundaries if
you find people and what they're doing
society and what's taking place to be
disgusting deplorable wrong or whatever
don't be afraid to take a stance tell
people how you feel I'm so tired of
everyone trying to skate around and
explain how everything going around in
our society today should be tolerated
and dealt with and completely accepted
at all points at all costs [__] although
I never feel like I've never although
I've never eaten a clam before somehow I
feel e that this shit's gotten out of
hand and if you feel like it's got out
of hand too tell the people around you
what you stand for well I did enjoy this
reaction video I did this was a very
good compilation I was thoroughly
entertained women hitting the wall it
actually had hit on a lot of topics
um you know the moral of the story is
guys looks don't last forever Beauty
does not last forever as women if you
get old enough eventually you're not
going to attract the attention you once
did it's okay it's part of life that's
why the women of times past used to
focus on character and other things like
family and relationships but you know
today it's really just looks looks looks
and that's why you get these crazy wives
honestly these super crazy wives but
anyways let me know what you guys think
in the comments like the video on your
way out to subscribe to the channel and
I'll talk to you next time